I've not had anything to eat since
breakfast
I've got no money to get any food or get
any drink
really hit me now how bad things are
really are
I've got 20p
to my name
that's it
toughest thing right now is probably me
worrying about mum
because she has all the pressure of the
bills the food the drink
everything that's keeping us alive
so it's quite hard for me to see her in
this state
we don't have a TV we don't have the
internet I don't drink or smoke I don't
go out there is no heating my fire is
the only source of heat
I feel like we've gone back in time
it is taking its toll massively to the
point last week I actually wanted to end
it all because I couldn't see a way out
because I feel like I'm on a roller
coaster that I just cannot get off
and there doesn't seem to be any way of
getting out of it whatsoever
it's like a vicious circle
but I'm trying
for the girl's sake
because I know there'd be loss about me
UK inflation has hit its highest level
in almost 30 years soaring food costs
and the energy crisis drive up prices
off gem has announced the new price cap
for an average fuel bill will rise 700
pounds it's February and a crisis is
building
the government steps in all domestic
electricity customers will receive an
upfront discount on their bills worth
200 pounds
it's not a handout it's a loan and every
household will have to appear
back a buy now pay later scheme that
loads up costs for tomorrow give with
one hand now and take it all back later
right okay what about um council tax how
much do you think you've already done
that so they're aware that you haven't
got any electric and they're still not
willing to help
the phones haven't stopped ringing here
all morning calls from Desperate
families trying to pay their bills
been in this industry for 26 years and
I've never seen it as Bleak as this and
I've had clients sit in front of me and
put a bottle of tablets and say I'm
going to take them but the council sent
me around to see you what can you do to
help me I feel like you're frustrated or
perhaps even getting a bit angry about
what lies ahead for people I'm
exceptionally angry because the help
from the government just isn't enough in
fact it's making the situation worse
is put everybody into 200 pound debt so
come October everybody has to pay a 200
pound back to their utility suppliers
over the next five years it's just not
acceptable at all
this is my outgoing
my rent council tax my gas and electric
my TV license with my water 383.
that's what's left in the month
but that's not including petrol photo
Diane has worked all her adult life
caring for the elderly she lives on her
own
six months earlier she had a heart
attack that's my morning pile and that's
my evening
can't afford to be off sick anymore so
she's going back to work I've got a fear
of not being able to pay my bills so you
get into bed and you're exhausted I mean
your whole body's exhausted but your
brain just don't switch off
so you laid there all night thinking
please go to sleep please go to sleep I
have no choice but to work till I'm 67
and I don't think I'll make it I'll be
honest if my health gets
if the chances of having another heart
attack pretty high
all I've got to look forward to now
worrying constantly about God how am I
going to pay for stuff
why can they not find money for the
people of this country that need it and
I hate to say this if there was a war
tomorrow that find money for it
they always do
breaking news this morning it is War
President Putin has announced the start
of a military operation
over the next few months the invasion of
Ukraine has huge implications for
Britain's economy today I'm announcing a
further 175 million pounds of UK aid for
Ukraine oil prices are soaring we're
already doing a huge amount to help
people with the immediate cost of living
the bank of England raised interest
rates to one percent today you are
making life tougher for families right
now aren't you well what would make it
even tough if a farmers as if inflation
kept on Rising even more
as Energy prices Skyrocket the
government rethinks its energy loan
support scheme
however the impact
so I've decided that those repayments
will be canceled we have decided that
the 200 pounds of support for household
energy bills
will be doubled to 400 pounds for
everyone
[Applause]
currently struggling to feed the kids I
think I've got about 40p to my name
did you shower last night yeah yeah I
could tell your hair's wet Danielle's a
single mum working part-time at a shop
in town these are her daughter's Brooke
and bryony
I've got a six pound 63 emergency
remaining and I owe seven pound eighteen
months just nine no
and then gas wise that's outside and I
hate I haven't even looked at it
recently because I don't you all 70 quid
yep
so you're in debt to the gas and you're
in debt to the electricity yeah and I
haven't even got anything emergency wise
on the gas so your gas is off at the
moment yeah you've got no gas no gas
because I can't afford to repay that
right now Danielle has no choice but to
self-disconnect from her gas according
to the citizens advice Bureau a record
number of households are doing the same
this year
not always most of the time
when I had bryony they said she's got a
heart murmur she's going to need open
heart surgery
she's got a hole in her heart
when it's cold she does get cold and you
can see slightly the her lips do tend a
little bit more blue
not having heating yeah is just not
ideal is it no
it is a worry
it affects me quite a lot because
obviously of the struggle with food
because obviously we get food from food
banks and everything's going up at the
moment and we're really struggling to
get money
how does it make you feel
quite sad and like it makes me feel very
sorry for mum for having to go through
this
seems to be getting
worse and this is probably the worst
I've been in a very long time to the
point where I'm having to go through the
sofas and that just to try and find the
old bit of change
how on Earth are you keeping it together
I'm not if I'm completely honest I have
to put a brave face on for the kids I
have to keep going for them even though
I work it I just
the work is my only Escape at the moment
because my mental Health's gone downhill
massively and I shed it all away
[Music]
at Westminster drama of the most
breathtaking Kinder leader unwilling to
go a party in Parliament determined to
force him out it is clearly now the
world of the Parliamentary conservative
party that there should be a new leader
of that party and therefore a new prime
minister
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
church we forget about everything we've
got this inner peace
atariba Sam and their three children
live in Salford in Greater Manchester
Sam works and atariba is currently
studying at University money's tight and
it's getting Tighter and so she has to
find new ways to make savings
of sun
this is a tomato I bought about a week
ago the remaining one I tend to take
some of the seeds out so I can plant you
know and see if I can start growing some
of my vegetables how long has it been
well it's been scanty I will say scanty
since um
last year September
what do you want to eat
noodles
sometimes we'll run out of electricity
sometimes we just stay in the dark it's
been very very difficult and that's why
at times I have to bring up friends you
know just to make sure there's food for
the kids can you can you loan me 50
pounds can you loan me 100 pounds in the
end of the month can you you know that's
what I've been doing
imagine when winter is fully here
because it's going to be a problem it
will end up converting what we'll use
for food to buy gas and electricity
that's what it means
and that's
that's a big problem
it'll be all right
all change at number 10 Liz truss gets
down to business after becoming the new
prime minister with a pledge on the cost
of living there are now high hopes that
a new prime minister will bring new
ideas
confidence is short-lived and the
nation's in for a shock we are talking
about an entire Credo of a new
government being put in the dumpster and
set on fire
I have just accepted Her Majesty the
Queens kind invitation to form a new
government
Liz truss says she'll protect people
from soaring energy bills from the 1st
of October a typical household will pay
no more than 2 500 pounds per year for
each of the next two years
foreign
the last time I saw Diane she was about
to return to work as a carer for the
elderly after having a heart attack a
few months earlier when I last saw you
all those months ago things were getting
a bit tough how would you describe
what's changed in the intervening months
um it's just got worse
financially
I'd say it's getting worse I just
canceled everything that I thought was
totally unnecessary
I can live without yeah I can do this
cut down as much as you can don't shop
as much
don't go out
but then you've no life
February the energy bills were starting
to creep up what's happened to your
energy bills since then
what well it's more than double at the
minute which just had obviously an
impact the rent's gone up twice it went
up in April then it went up again in
October my rent's gone up twice yeah
well how would you describe how this
whole crisis has left you feeling
vulnerable
and
angry angry because I I feel like
there's nothing I can do
I feel stuck
because all I can say is the same old
same old rhetoric on the on the TV the
same people spouting off the same that
they always spout off
how would you sum up how things have
gone for you
badly
yeah badly
we promised a new approach for a new era
we promised to release the enormous
potential of this country
the new Chancellor quasi quateng
announces a raft of tax cuts but doesn't
explain how it'll be funded the markets
are sent into turmoil
the pound has fallen to its lowest ever
level against the dollar during early
Trading
mood out there is pretty mutinous even
MPC back to list trust for leadership
feel that there's been a series of own
goals
at the moment I'm living day to day with
everything going on with
prime minister and stuff
obviously there's a big worry at the
moment
and I don't know what that's going to
mean for me
I'm
hoping that something happens and it
becomes good but here's a worry
I don't know what the future brings
hello how are you doing
it's good to see you yeah you too it's
stone cold in Danielle's house her and
her daughter's Brooke and bryony have
had no heating on for months now all
they have is an open fire that's it
I feel like every day
it's just another fight it's just
what are they going to eat today how am
I going to keep the house warm
how am I going to get them to school how
am I going to you know just
it's just
trying to get through one day at a time
and it's a struggle
at night I struggled to get to sleep
because I think what if this time next
year I'm not in this place what if I'm
in a completely different place or I'm
in a homeless shelter or I'm out on the
streets or something I keep on thinking
at night everything's gonna be okay and
that eventually it will all be fixed and
we'll all be Orion everything will be a
okay from here
Danielle says the money from the
government's energy support scheme has
helped to keep the lights on
thanks to that 66 pound that we got I've
still got quite a bit of electric left
which is really lucky because I was
about to run out
next week look like I don't know do not
know I don't even plan that far ahead
yeah
[Music]
this is where I spend all of my evening
my little heater goes on before bed
and as soon as I get up in the morning
to try and make it more bearable it's my
safe place but it's also my worst place
everything hits me when the kids are in
bed
so it is it's my sanctuary and my dark
place
[Music]
I know who art get that from
some breaking news to bring you this
afternoon two sources now saying that
quasiquating has lost his job and it
does appear that Liz truss has tried to
save her Premiership by blaming her ex
Chancellor today I have asked Jeremy
Hunt to become the new Chancellor
pray about not being afraid in Salford
part-time Pastor Sam is about to lead
the Sunday service
praise the Lord amen oh come on people
praise the Lord
when I was eight years close everything
was fine until suddenly one day my
father woke up in the morning
and walked out of our lives
that's what I understood what Darkness
was all about
I cried
I mourned until I found Jesus
I read the most in the cool classic well
done well done oh yeah yeah yeah
as the head of the family I feel the
burden is on me
there are times
I feed everybody out because I am I am
in deep sorrow even at times I don't
talk to her she talks to me I don't
reply because not because I don't want
to talk to her but because I don't speak
what's going on I feel I I am
disappointing my family I can't provide
can't meet their needs do you feel his
pain absolutely
absolutely
he doesn't need to speak the whole world
has crumbled on us
has collapsed on us
who
it's
hard
you know
the rise and the cost of living is
hitting the poorest households hardest
many turn to Charities for help and
advice
Sylvia yes how are you doing I'm all
right it's lovely to see you and lovely
to see you too it's been a few months
hasn't it
how has demand changed since we last
spoke
demand has increased oh I'd say
threefold threefold threefold and the
first half of this year demanded
increase by 400 percent we're at the
point where there's no food and there's
no money for gas and electric it's it
feels chaotic because of the amount of
help that people need
and there isn't enough resources out
there to give it to everybody
how do you feel about the twoing and
throwing of political decisions
and the impact that it's had on on
families it just made me angry it makes
me really really angry because they
don't see the Fallout from those
decisions it's like they haven't got a
clue if they were to come and Shadow a
service like ours then they might have a
clue and might decide differently this
is really about survival where we work
people lock in bins for food we've had
the police tell us that they'd stop
people at 10 o'clock at night and said
excuse me Lads what are you doing and
they've responded with oh sorry officer
we're looking for some food
yeah it's about survival
absolutely
I am resigning as leader of the
conservative party
I understand that I have work to do to
restore trust after all that has
happened
after a year of hardship for many
inflations Rising interest rates are
rising and tensions are rising too
the government's support for households
has helped limit the damage caused by
this cost of living crisis
but millions of households are poorer
now
it's constant
just constant going out into a
supermarket and thinking put that back
you don't need that don't buy that
that's too expensive
this isn't
living
this is just surviving
it is just surviving
I'm just keeping the roof over my head
just paying my bills there is nothing
left
our kids
they're still growing
they're actually growing we don't want
them to be malnourished you know
that's our biggest worry
Danielle is slipping behind with her
rent and there's a very real prospect
that she could be evicted
she's coming to terms with a stark
reality she doesn't have enough money to
live on anymore
I don't know how I'm gonna face
Christmas if I'm completely honest I
think it is going to be the case of
little little things that cost nothing
but
it's all I can do I can't plan for
tomorrow I just gotta just deal with it
when it comes